con ansiedad estas personas esperan a
las afueras del puerto de pemba mientras
tratan de ubicar a sus familiares que
lograron llegar a un lugar seguro
decenas de sobrevivientes llegaron en
barcos este jueves luego del ataque
ocurrido la semana pasada en la ciudad
de palmas a 200 kilómetros de allí un
gran alivio para algunos mientras que
otros temen por aquellos de los que no
se tiene noticia
estoy muy cansada pasé siete días en los
arbustos estoy exhausta nos cruzamos
varias veces con los atacantes la
situación es realmente difícil muchas
personas muriesen
más de 8000 personas la mitad de ellas
niños han sido forzadas a desplazarse de
acuerdo con naciones unidas y muchas más
viven bajo difíciles condiciones
mientras esperan su turno para ser
evacuadas aún hay muchas personas
alrededor de 5000 esperando para ser
evacuadas a pemba borde y se están
quedando sin comida y sin agua
la evacuación fue impulsada por un
ataque de yihadistas ocurrido en la
ciudad de palma hace una semana docenas
de personas fueron asesinadas mientras
que cientos de militantes vinculados con
el estado islámico atacaron tiendas
bancos e instalaciones militares los
soldados se encuentran en la zona
tratando de asegurar la ciudad entonces
aún no hemos asegurado toda la ciudad
estamos patrullando y consolidando las
áreas principales mientras desplazamos a
nuestros soldados para proteger el
perímetro el ataque es la mayor escalada
de la insurgencia islamista que inició
en el norte de mozambique en 2017 y
hasta el momento deja más de 2500
asesinados y alrededor de 700.000
desplazados